did you attend the med gala
i did i
i got out of the car and walked the red
carpet by myself
escorted by somebody from
ralph lauren's team
and
i sat next to an empty place setting for
johnny
um that they
they cleared as soon as we realized that
he wasn't
that he effectively stood me up on the
carpet
who did you meet at the met
gala i
was standing in line um right in front
of a gentleman
it was elon
i didn't recognize him
until we when we started talking
and he had reminded me that we had met
once before he was with his mother
okay
and did you strike up a friendship with
mr musk after that
we did we um as i mentioned we spoke on
the on the red carpet kind of on the
waiting
in the waiting line
of the carpet and
he seemed like a
real gentleman he was really nice and
he sat next to me well not next to me he
sat
kind of in a nearby table and we got to
speaking that night and then eventually
became friends i pick up the phone
and
and try to you know
apologize
for
the fact that my
husband at the time just screamed at my
friend
on a cold call
um i didn't want io to think that's why
i had called io you know to just be
screamed at and blamed for something
that sounded crazy for lack of a better
explanation it sounded crazy
io
said something to me on speakerphone
and
reminded me i wasn't safe objection on
or hearsay your honor it's not offered
to prove the truth of the matter it's to
show what caused mr depp to be set off
and come back i i mean it's not offered
to prove the truth of what he's saying
it's not hearsay i'll overall objection
thank you please tell us what io said
and what then happened with mr depp
io said amber get out of the house get
out of the house now you're not safe
get out of that house
i had been there
after the cleanup or for the cleanup
after december 15 2015 incident
objection
responses
all right i think she can provide the
context i'll sustain the objection next
question so please please continue
johnny hears this
when he's on the stairs he made it up
one flight of stairs
heard this turned around came bolting
down the stairs
grabbed the phone from my hand
and really
really started screaming this time let
into io
called io
every imaginal every imaginable horrible
name that you can
say to a lgbt per cubic person for one
and and any person any human being ever
i mean just screamed
at io um
some really nasty stuff and he when he's
done he says you know you want to you
want to have you want to have my woman
now you want to have my [ __ ] you can
have you you take her you can have her
and he
with that picks up just pulls his arm
back with the phone and throws it at my
face
hit me
right in my it felt like my eye
i put my
head in my hands
and immediately
start crying
um i
said you hit me with the phone johnny
you hit me
and i'm sitting on the couch i didn't
even have time to
react you know i i didn't have time to
put my hands up i was still
sitting cross-legged in my
socks
on the couch and i haven't seen him for
a month and last you know several times
now that i've seen him
he's hit me and i didn't even have time
to react to this
he comes over to me
as i'm crying
and
he does that taunting thing
to me
he says oh yeah i hit you huh i hit you
yeah
and he just
feels like whacks me on top of my head
and just this heavy
ringed hand landed on top of my
my skull grabs me by the hair yanks me
up off the couch i'm struggling to stand
up
and i don't know if he was intending to
hit me in the face or if he was just
trying to grab my face but he was making
this
um gesture around my face to try to hold
to expose my face to him and he was like
yeah let me see how bad i hurt you let
me see it let me see how bad i hurt you
this time what if i pull your hair back
what if i pull your hair back
and
he yanks my hair back i'm trying to
prevent
him from landing the blows to my face
and trying to prevent my face from being
exposed
and i just remember this mocking
taunt he was doing with me as he
is
yanking me around the room
what did you do as a result of knowing
that the police were coming
i i felt panicked i
i didn't know what to do
because
i didn't know what they were going to do
when they saw
the state of the place he'd also smashed
up the other apartment where i kept all
my things so i didn't know what they
were gonna do and i panicked i called
um i called the only lawyer i have which
is my
entertainment lawyer he does like my
movie contracts and stuff
and i asked him for advice
and then
without telling what he said
what happened next
i called a domestic relations attorney
after that conversation and had you
known this domestic relations attorney
before then no i did not did you get
that name from your entertainment
attorney yes i did okay and when you
called the domestic relations attorney
without saying what she said
what did you do as a result
i
told the police officers who arrived
that i would not objection your honor
hearsay i cannot offer to prove the
truth of the matter asserted all right
overall objection go ahead thank you
i'm sorry could you repeat that
i repeated to the officers i refused to
cooperate at this time at the advice of
my attorney my best friend
took pictures of me
we took pictures of the house and my
face
okay
i'm going to
and
did your best friend take any pictures
while the officers were there
we took pictures before
and while they were there and after okay
we took pictures throughout
okay
so i'm going to take you now michelle
can you bring up defendants exhibit 706.
i think we can do the native on this one
yes thank you
uh does this accurately depict the scene
portrayed
yes it does your honor i'd like to move
the admission of defendant 706.
no objection 706 in evidence
and would you please describe to the
jury what this is a picture of
this is um my face after johnny threw a
phone at it at the time it felt like the
hardest thing i've ever had to do
i had worked so hard
to try to make this relationship work
i went to therapy and went to al-anon i
got help i read books i did everything i
could possibly do and it didn't work
and um
i finally was i was conflicted to answer
your question i was conflicted i knew
after he threw the phone at my face that
after all that that month of not seeing
each other
not getting better not getting clean and
sober there wasn't even
i didn't you know the the
the the
oh it was falling apart i knew i had i
knew i had to leave him i knew i i
wouldn't
i knew i wouldn't survive it if i didn't
so
i made the decision to
to file for divorce
it was hard because um
you know i loved johnny so much
i loved him so much
and why did you file for divorce
because i knew if i didn't
that i knew if i did not likely not
literally survive
i'm britain
i'm so scared that it was gonna end
really badly
for me
and i am
i really didn't want to leave him
i loved him
much
i wouldn't have done anything but i
couldn't
i couldn't do that one thing i couldn't
stay
the promise and the hope that i had i
had become less and less regular and
more and more rare
the monster had been this thing that was
now the normal and not the exception
the violence was now normal and not the
exception and
it was um so
so hard
it was so hard but i knew i had to do it
nobody
[Music]
i'm believing would have
taken it too far
i wouldn't be here
you